just in time for the warmer temperatures  outdoor water parks at ymcas across the  valley they're now open  that includes the locations at  centennial durango hills the meadow  lanes location as well  water parks are open from noon to five  most days and on fridays from two to  seven  and north las vegas splash pads and  pools opening this week  they're available starting wednesday  through sunday across  across the city of north las vegas from  noon to six the silver mesa recreation  center pool that's still under some  maintenance right now  that'll open at a later date as for the  city of las vegas it's pavilion center  and municipal pools  they reopened today